はい ではよろしくお願いします
今月の説法会ですね 法話
これから始まります 今日のテーマは
ご覧の通り ブッダの寛容論ということで
で 私はなんで私にこんなテーマを頼まれるのかとね
寛容って全く糸かけもない人間でね
まあちょっと苦しいんですけど
もうサブはまあ仏教はおおらかな教えですかっていうことで
まあとにかくまあ 寛容という言葉について仏教の内容を喋りたいんですね
これは英語で喋った方が随分便利で簡単だと思いますけど
一応英語になってくるとそういう風になります
まああの あまり英語で喋れません
今日は tolerance of the Buddha ということでやりますね
で サブタイトルは私は入れましたけど
Does the Buddha play to the tunes of others?
人の言うように いわゆるまあという
何でしたっけね これを日本語にすると
で お釈迦様は寛容だからといってね
人の言いなりに遊ばせることはできません
ですから Does the Buddha play to the tunes of others? と書いたんですね
では テーマに入ってみましょうか tolerance
という 一応寛容という言葉より
私はこの tolerance という言葉に集中して項目をなり作ったんです
英語の言葉は tolerance ですね
で 定義としてはね 他人の意見
信仰 行動 生き方 生活 習慣
主義などは たとえ自分自身のそれらと違っていても
受け入れること 認めること
弾劾しないことなんですね
まあ主になんか考えということになっちゃうんで
考えで信仰ですね この定義で入ってないのは
私は入れましたけど あえてこの生活習慣
西洋の定義では入れてないんですね
西洋哲学でも tolerance という言葉はあるんですけど
どうもなんか取り方がちょっと違うなと
西洋では流行り始めた言葉で
あの 西洋文化でもね 初めからあった単語じゃないんですよ
これは別な単語を組み合わせて
今日それは忘れちゃったんですけど
作った言葉なんですね tolerance
というね 明治時代では日本語にもなったそうですね
寛容なんか全くなかった
西洋では相手の意見 信仰などを弾劾する残酷さに気づいてできた考えなんですね
だから西洋人っていうのは
やっぱり我々よりはかなりスピーディーに成長するんだから
まるっきり成長遅れている人もいますけど
まあ一般的に言えばかなりスピーディーに成長するんですね
だから この激しい争争節する
硬くてね 俺の意見のみ正しいと
お前は殺してやるぞと
違う意見を持ってるんだからというぐらい
ものすごい原始的 残酷な歴史があるんですね
皆様も映画なんかでも知ってるけど
魔女狩りとかまでありましたからね
宗教裁判というものもありますけど
英語でインクイジションといいますね
勝手な何人かがアホな何人かがね
人を裁いてもう処刑にするんですよ
意見違うだけで そこで生物学の本なんか今ちょっと読んでますけど
いまだに足引っ張られてるんですね
生物学の本だから 科学的に淡々と生物の進化の過程書けばいいのに
これは西洋ではいかに難しいかというのは
科学でしょうに だからいまだにアメリカ人口のまあ五十パーセントはないんだけど
まあ四十八パーセントぐらい
やっぱり地球の寿命は一万年ぐらいで
人間は神が作ったに決まっているんだと
進化は間違っていると
で この間もあるイスラム教の方なんですけども
私は進化論なんかはね
これはただの推測 仮定でやってみてませんと
私もまあ推測なんですけど
でも問題はすべてファクツ
事実 データに基づいた推測ですからね
しょうがないでしょう
しかし しかし その人は私は言ったんですよ
このダーウィンさんが言ってるような進化論が
私は知りませんよと 外国のことだからね
しかし 人は知ってますよと
女性のお腹の中でずっと進化するんだよと
人間は 10ヶ月とかの間で
それは否定できますかと
あなたにはと言ったら
それはそうですねと話が終わりました
で なんでそういうことを言うのかというと
やはりこのその辺でね
西洋といえば日本か まあインドは違いますけど
インドの西ですね で かなり硬いんですね
頭狭かったんですね だから硬くて狭かったんだからこそ
科学は爆発して発展したり
新しいものを開発したりとかね
それはすごくありがたいことなんですね
だから この残酷な生き方を自分たちがやっているんだから
いろんなところで哲学者
思想家 宗教家やらね いろんな人々は
この これまずいんじゃないんですかね
人は自分の意見ね フリーシンキングですね
フリーダムオブシンキングというんですけどね
それってあって悪くないでしょということになって
トレードですよね まあじゃあ我慢しましょうということになったんですよ
では インドになってみましょう
古代インドでは これ あの
この R の下 点入れてますけど
本当は I というあれ 母音入れなくちゃあかんだけどね
私は入れてないんですね
なぜならばサンスクリット語で R
それだけでも母音入ってるんです
リュックヴェーダというもんですね
発音を覚えてください
リュックヴェーダ で これはあのアスタと同じくすごい古い聖典なんです
聖典って言うんだけど
誰か誰かさんがね 書いた歌なんですけど
紀元前 3000年は古いんですね
このようなくだりがあります
この場所は 1 の 164 の 46 のラインですね
3番目のラインでエカンサットヴィップラバフダワダンティ
面白いことあります 私は昨日
リュックヴェーダの結構ものすごい大きい本ですけどね
ざっと 第1章から最後の第10章なんですね
ざっと目を通してみたんですけど
あの あれは歌ですからね
歌の節はね ブッダンサラナンガッチャミっていうのは節になっているんです
サーヴィトリという歌の作り
文字の数え方がありまして
このサーヴィトリチャンダスできていて
もうやっぱり原文で読んでみたらなんか面白いんですね
私たちはブッダンサラナンガッチャミ
ダンマンサラナンガッチャミ
サンガンサラナンガッチャミ
三行ですよね 後では詩には四行必要なんです
しかし ブッダサラなんか言っちゃえば三行で終わっちゃうんですね
このリグヴェーダでも全部三行で終わるんですね
最後の十章になってくると
四行の歌もたくさん出てくるんです
で こちらでこのエーカンザットビプラバウダワダンティ
真理は一つです 賢者は様々な言葉でそれを語りますという意味なんです
で ヒンドゥー教は自分たちがすごい寛容的であるとかなり宣伝しています
それで 彼らにとっては最高の聖典から一行引用できているんです
だからタオランスに遠慮しているというテーマで調べれば
必ずこれサンスクリット語で出てきませんだけど
一応この意味の言葉はちゃんと引用していると思います
いろいろテキストを調べたんですけど
場所も書いてなかったんですね
だから私はひどい目に遭ったんですよ
あんな面白くもない ものすごい紀元前三年という古いテキストを舐めなくちゃくれなくなっちゃったんだからね
しかし リグヴェーダは多神教を語るんですよ
同じ神に名前が複数という意味だと私は思います
で あの行だけ取り切って話しちゃうと
当然あの寛容なんですね
いわゆる真理は同じだよと
これ発見した人は自分の言葉で語ってるんだから
言葉が変わりますよ 気にすんなよと
いう意味になりますね
切って取り出しちゃうと
コンテキストから それで私はどうせ悪口の私のあれだからね
性格だからコンテキストの中に入れて読んだんですね
そうすると亀 風やら火やら雷やら川やら山やら
そういうものを神に仕立てて歌っているところで
同じ雷にしたっても 結構名前が結構出るんですね
同じ風の神であっても
いくつかの名前が出てくるんですね
あの四季も神にしているんですね
ワルナというね そういうことで
ワルナ神にも名前がいくつかあるんですね
だからそれで喧嘩するなよということではないかなと
と思います はい それだけですね
ヒンドゥー教の あの それだけではないんですよ
今日はちょっとかなりずれますから
あの 全部紹介することはできないんです
結構あります じゃあ 我々の立場から考えましょう
歴史はどうでもいいんです
寛容であるとは  1相手のことを我慢する
これはやっぱり怒りが絡む
絡むでしょ 我慢すると
2自分を主張するのは怖い
あんたそう言ったっても
私は違うと思います 私はこういう考えだよとね
怖くて言えないんですね
だから恥ずかしいでしょうね
なんか気が弱くて  3自分に別に何か意見があるのではない
自分にとってはアホでね
別にどうでもいいんですよ
だから人がAという意見 B
という意見 Cという意見と言ったって
ああそうかそうか ああ
なるほど そうそう それで終わっちゃうんですね
あれで寛容なんですね
あのね あなたのこれ  Aという意見とこのCという意見がちょっと合わないねとか
それは言わない 要は自分にとっては別に何の意見もないということでね
これどちらかというと結構無知型なんですね
というわけで 結構アホにも寛容でいられますよ
アホだから これでいいのかっていう問題なんですね
4相手の意見をよく理解できない
これはまあ私にもあるような気がしますけど
時々日本の方々はあれやこれやあれやこれやと理屈つけて
私にいろんなものを言うんですけど
何言ってるかさっぱりわからなくなっちゃうんですね
私の思考パターンがちょっと違いますからね
ああ そうですね まあまあ
それはそれでいいんじゃないかと
すごい寛容な態度をとるんです
本当は寛容な態度をとる性格じゃないんですよ
この人は何言ってるかさっぱりわからないんだから
一応寛容な態度でも取ろうかなと
5番目 皆に自分の意見を持つ自由があるという持っている
それはごく一般的ですね
我々も皆様もみんなそう思っていると思いますよ
人には自分の意見を持つ自由があると
でも子供が何か言ったら怒るでしょう
自分の意見を持つ自由があると言いつつも
結局はもう 言っちゃいますね
6番目は相手の意見にも一理あるということ
それもなんかかっこよさそうに見えるんですね
まあ私にはかっこよさそうに見えません
5番目は普通ですね 格好よりも良いも悪くもなく
まあ人には意見を持つ自由があるっていう
こんなこと偉そうなこと言わなくても
人は自分の意見持っているんだからね
たとえ無知な人であっても
とんでもない愚か者であっても
それなりに自分の意見を持ってるんですよ
こんな偉そうなこと言わなくたってもね
あなたにはあなたの意見を持つ自由がありますよとかね
大きな嘘です それは もうそこで私は問題にするのは
私はそれを実行しているのかっていうことなんです
人は自分の意見持ってます
それは これはもう  何でしたっけね
生命ならね みんなやってることなんですよ
しかし 私たちっていうのは
自分が意見を持ってるくせに
人の意見にいろんなケチをつけたり
ケチつけてもいいんです
批判してもいいんですけど
認めないこと 皆様はその経験ない場合は
自分の家族のことを考えてください
家族の人 他のメンバーたちの意見を尊重しているかないかと
どこまで行ったっけ？ 7番目
ああ  6番目 もう一回戻りましょう
この相手の意見にも一理あるっていうのはね
なんか賢そうに見えますね
まあ私は思考が浅いと思いますよ
人の意見をわかるということは
一理あるだけじゃなくて
長所 短所 論理の成り立ち
成り立ち これは整理しているかないか
そこまで知っておかないと知ったことになりません
ああ そういえばっていうのは
あんまりいい立場じゃないんですよ
7番目は相手の意見は気にするほどのものではない
ちょっとちっちゃな子供がね
私 大きくなったらなんとかなりますとね
まあまあ 何でしたっけ
電車の運転士になりますと
ああ そうですね ああ よかったねと言って親が終わっちゃうでしょ
子供の意見は相手にしてないんですね
時々私は勘定をかぶりますよ
その時は相手の意見は気にするほどのものではないということで無視しているんです
これで観念をかぶりできますかね
特に子供と喋る場合はみんなそうやっちゃいますよ
私ならすぐ乗ります 子供の話に
将来必ずそうなるなるわけないという大人だから知ってますけど
しっかり子供は電車の運転士になりたいと言ったら
ああ それは面白そうですね
あんたは操縦知ってるのかい？とかね
何線のはいいんですかね？とかね
それは新幹線だったらばっかりでかいんだ
あれもかっこいいやと
いろいろ話に乗ってあげるんです
ローカル線はあんまり人が乗らないんだからね
山手線だったらね すごくいいでしょうとかね
だからやっぱり人の意見っていうのは大事にした方がいいんですよ
はい 八 そのうちうち相手も自分を理解するでしょう
これも親がよくやりますね
今 子供はまるっきり違う意見でももう喧嘩しているんですね
だから  そのうち子供はわかるでしょう
ということで 観念をかぶるんです
これ 観念じゃないんですね
結局は自分の意見に賛成してほしいんです
9番目 表現と実行の仕方が違っていても
皆同じ真理を語っているという
ヴェーダ聖典に対してみんな言っていることで
これは私は結構白人からよく聞く話なんですね
で 西洋で書かれている
英語で書かれた本では
本なんかではいつでもこれはよく出るんですね
よくかっこつけて まあすいません
いろいろ言葉でいろんな用語を使ってみんな語ってますけど
まあ真理は同じですから
まあいいんじゃないという感じなんですね
で 私はそちらにケチつけたいんですね
本当にそうなのかと  10番目
世は多事多様多色ですという立場
世の中っていうのはいろいろあるもんだから
これ決して悪い立場じゃないと思いますよ
だっていろいろあるんだからね
それで私は口先でそう言うんだけど
本当に本気でやっぱりいろいろありますよと認めているのかい？と
なんで学校で子供たちはいじめられますかね
特に私は外人だから 外人の子供たちがどれほどひどい目に遭っているのかと
なんか野生の猿の群れに入ったような感じなんですね
だからそれは結局は親の育ちでしょ
自分と違う人のことも大事にしなさいと教えてないんです
だから この口先でではね
まあ世の中は多岐多様
多色やとね 言うんだけど
これは小さい時からもう理解した方がいいと思いますよ
それで立派な人間になります
11は他の意見に興味関心はありませんと
えらい内向的というか
引きこもりというかね
鍵かけて興味ないんだと
それで観念的に見えちゃうんですね
12番目は批判否定されるのはやばいという
これ結構聞いてますよ
皆様からも 結構質問として受けているので
私は 会社でね 自分いろいろ意見は言いたいんだけど
やっぱり批判されるのは嫌で
怖くて言えないんだと
どうすればいいんですかと
で 私はただあの まあ数字がいいんだから
12で終わっちゃったんです
別に理由がないんです
本当に 12しかないのかと
まあそこら辺でいいんじゃないかなと 12
まで行ったんだからね
で 等々のような理由を挙げられますが
決してクールな理性的な立場とは言い切れません
ということで 私は何を言いたいのかというと
まあどんな人間でも まあ私だって結構観念的よと言いたいんですよ
私はそんな自分エゴわがままじゃないよと
もうそんな自分の意見を主張しようともとんでもない
そんな気持ちは毛頭ないんだよと
人の意見はもうちゃんとそれなりに認めますよというバッジをつけたいんですよ
みんなつけているんです
そこで私は あなたはどんな理由でこのバッジをもらったのかということを理由自由に書いたんです
皆様に適したものがあったらその使ってください
はい では 仏教の寛容 真理と寛容の両立は難しいんです
だからこれが問題なんです
そんなに簡単な軽い話ではないんです
曖昧で根性のない寛容はありません
仏教においては この曖昧で根性のない寛容なんかはありません
で このウィキペディアでね
この一応ページのあれ名前書きましたけど
すべての宗教に寛容性があるのごとく書いてます
これ批判しようかなと思ったんですけど
まあやめました で いろんな宗教の文章を引用して
こちらの寛容性やあちらの寛容性
ユダヤ教にもキリスト教にもイスラム教にも素晴らしい寛容性あるとかね
ヒンドゥー教にもあるとか
ヒンドゥー教は寛容ですけど
引用している聖書のコテージは全部寛容を否定するコテージなんですね
しかし 寛容でありながら真理を主張する仏教には問題があるように記してるんですよ
このウィキペディアの記事を書いた人がね
まあそれに別に我々は寛容性があるんだから
そこを訂正しようとはしなかったんです
面白いでしょ イスラム教にも寛容があるんだけど
仏教にはないんだというのは
しかし 他宗教に対する引用のすべては差別思考に優れているんです
例えばユダヤ教のね 旧約聖書と新約キリスト教の方々というところに
エジプトの人々のことをあまり悪く思うなかれと
それは寛容であると で
理由は書いていますよ
我々は客としてこの国にいるんだからと
客じゃなくて奴隷でしたけど
まあそこはいいんですけど
これって差別でしょ 私たちは偉いんだけど
今エジプトで苦労しています
だからエジプト人を憎しみたいんですよ
それで自分の本に いえ
これはダメですよと あんた方は今この国で客としているんだから
ちょっと我慢しろよというニュアンスなんですね
何の寛容もないんですよ
差別なんです イスラム教でも
あるんで言葉あるんです
寛容に その言葉でユダヤ教とキリスト教に寛容にしなさいと
あの 何といいますか 本を信仰する人々という用語なんですね
いわゆるユダヤ教にもキリスト教にも聖書という本がありまして
それはパクってコーランを作ったんですよ
だからコーランだけ神の言葉と言ったって
あれパクったですけどね
神がどうやってと私は思いますけど
まあそれはいいんだけど
その人々のことも寛容に寛容するしかないです
そちらからデータが盗んだんだから
ユダヤ教の聖書から しかし
ランクはダウンなんです
だから神を信じる宗教なら
一応イスラム教はそんなに激しいことはしません
で 仏教の国々でもイスラム教はいるんですけど
私たちはえらい立場が強いんだから
まあこいつらを寛容するしかないということで
寛容とされてはいるんです
負けませんだから仏教は
そういうことで まあ別に宗教だからしょうがないんだけど
これ差別主義なんですね
結局は 弾圧 弾劾 裁き 戦争
黒人差別 ユダヤ人殺し
テロ行為 戦争などは聖書の権威で行ってきたんです
各宗教は寛容を謳っているんだと言ったっても
現実はそういうものなんです
全然寛容的でない講演ですね
仏教の寛容性はものすごく研究されています
だから私は全然面白くない
自分で調べるものはほとんどわかったんだからね
だから話も面白くないんです
どうしようもないんです
なんか面白くする方法はあるのか考えたんですけど
ないんです もう 全部もうとっくに学者たちが研究しています
そこであの一番目 このタランスアンドダイバーシティという記事がありまして
これインターネットに出ています
これは本 小さな本 パンフレットなんですけど
インターネットで無料で読めます
で アクセスアドレスはこのアドレスなんですね
ビッグボディっていうのは野暮さんでお坊さんで
アメリカ人で もう仏教学の博士で
ものすごい立派に文章を書くんです
すごく研究して書く方
お坊さんです アメリカ人ですけど
それからこの次の記事を私は一応持ってきましたけど
クリティカルタレランスオプションフォーブッディストインマルチカルチャルソサイエティという
国連かどこかでなんかあって
発表会やって そこで発表された論文なんですね
一応持ってきましたけど
それは皆様も読んだ方がいいんじゃないかなと思うんです
そこはそんな長くはないんです
11ページぐらいです
で これ書いた先生がまあすごくいい先生で
私は大学にいた頃 一緒に仕事をした先生なんですね
すっごい真剣に研究して論文を書くんです
アクセスはこのアドレスなんですけどね
そのように詳しく研究されています
仏教の寛容について また
一般人に読める本もありますよ
マレーシアのクアラルンプールのお寺の住職をやったり
亡くなられたんですけど
ケイスイダンマーナンダという長老がお坊さんが書いたトラランスインブディズムという本がありまして
英語はすごいシンプルで
まあ母国語ではなくセカンドランゲージとして英語を使う人々には読みやすいと思います
この記事を読むためには
やっぱりまあ英語の能力はちょっと問われます
私はすごくいいと今日持ってきたものは
まあ学術的な論文ですから
結構大変だと思いますよ
これは まあ英語の使い方はね
はい これでまあ私は先生方に漏れたところ
ちょこちょこっと これは漏れてないんです
特にパリワデン先生の記事ではほとんど漏れてないんです
必要なデータは全部揃っています
サッビーサッタバワンドスギタッタ
聞いたことありますかね
初めて聞きますかね これはテーラワーダ仏教の序文ですからね
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
これはブッダの戒めですね
あの これを覚えてください
すごいお守りになります
ですから 仏教では寛容ではなくて差別はありません
英語で言えば  It is not tolerance in Buddhism We
don't mean Buddhist don't maintain discrimination
すごく違います 寛容と差別同じだと思う？違います
そこで生きとし生けるものがといえば
命持っているものはみんな幸せであってほしいと
だから一切区別差別ないんです
このスタンスで生活すると
その人は自ずから寛容的になります
だから仏教の寛容というのはこう簡単じゃないんです
まず慈悲を実践する 実践して
すべての生命も自分も対等で感じられる人間として成長する
それからどうでもいいんです
生命は対等で見られるならば
寛容やら何だらかんだらそんなくだらないことを言えなくなっちゃいます
すごく楽に生きられます
しかし 人のことを無視して無関心でいることは慈しみになるのでしょうかと
そこで 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと念じるだけで
しかし 私は人のことは無視する
気にしない 関係ない 興味ないという態度でいると
質問がありますね あなたは本当に慈しみの人ですか？と
だから慈しみの人が余計なことはしないんだけど
いわゆる許す範囲で 人々のことには興味を持つ
手を伸ばす 関わりを持つ
それはもしかすると野生の動物かもしれませんし
人間かもしれませんし
まあ自分にできる範囲で
他の生命との関わりを持つんです
だから仏教の慈悲 慈しみから生まれるこの優しさ
人を認めることで このポイントもあります
次 他の幸福のためにできる範囲で活動しなくてはならないんですよ
だから寛容 だ寛容だと言い張っている場合でなくなる時もあります
人の幸せを本当に思う
それでこの人 この人 この人
この人の場合は 私に幸せになるために手伝ってあげることできるとわかったらやらなくちゃいけないでしょ
一切生命が幸福になってほしいんだけど
私個人にはそれはちょっと無理なんですね
実行するのは しかし 私の周りにいる何人か何人かのことは
なんか放っておけなくなります
協力しなくちゃいけなくなります
ですから 仏教の慈しみっていうのはそういうことで
ただ無関心でいることではなくて
自分にできる範囲で人のことにも関わった方がいいということになるんです
はい 次に行きましょう
差別とバイアス バイアスはおそらく日本語でこの先入観
でしょうと思います この 2つは寛容の敵です
もし人は差別意識を持っているならば
その人は決して寛容な人間だと言えません
もし人にバイアスがあるならば
先入観があるならば かなり危険人物なんです
つい 差別になったり 寛容的でなくなったりはする恐れがあります
だから敵ですね 仏教は差別を
バイアスをなくすことをミス入ってますね
すいません 私が書いた日本語だからね
ちょっと文章間違ってますけどね
点なんですけど ではなくてね
仏教は差別 バイアス これなくすことを推薦しています
寛容になりなさいと言ってないんです
差別なくせ 先入観なくせと
したがって 差別主義を無視しないで
理性に基づいて批判します
それでお釈迦様はかなり厳しく差別主義を批判する
これには大量にデータがあります
バラモンのカースト制度の批判
仏典を読んでみると ボロクソにバラモン人をバカにしているんです
お釈迦様が何をバカにしているかというと
このカースト制度なんですね
バラモン人を馬鹿にしてないんです
だから面白いことは あれほど散々お釈迦様はバラモン人を批判するのに
バラモン人の間で釈尊というのは我々のことを本当にマジ心配するんだよと
と言うんです しかし ものすごくクッタクタ言われてますよ
お釈迦様に言われているのに
自分たちのことを心配する人であると
バラモンの人々言うことが
このバラモンの母とバラモンの父が産んだ子供は生まれバラモンでしょ
それで聖職者ですよと
他の人々はその人を拝むべきですよと
母親がバラモン人だからという
自分たちが社会特権取るんですね
他の人々は生まれによって差別するんですね
これお釈迦様は認めません
お釈迦様はある時こう言うんですね
これすごい辛口というかね
これも同じことでお釈迦様は批判したんですね
あなたは禿 いわゆるバラモン人から見れば
髪の毛を剃ることはすごい恥ずかしいことなんです
なのに今平気でやっているんです
経典を見ると もう頭を剃っていることで結構貶されたんですけど
ムンダカサマナカーとかね
ムンダカっていうのは禿ということで
バンドゥパーダパッチャ
梵天の足の裏から生まれたやつらやと
すごい厳しい非難 侮辱的な単語を使ってます
パーリ経典では記録があります
それでお釈迦様に対してね
羽目方はね 禿でね 髪の足の裏から生まれた連中でね
我々は生まれつき聖職者だよと
そしたらお釈迦様は何のことなく
あのね 私は知ってますよと
昔々のバラモン人はものすごく立派な性格でしたよと
今一人もその立派な性格を守ってないんだと
本当に淡々と語っていくんですよ
えらい気づくようにあえて計算して
バラモン人が言って悪かった
ごめんなさいと謝るところまで持っていくんです
どういう風に言うかというと
昔のバラモン人がこの血統を清らかにする目的で
いかなる場合があっても
バラモンの男はバラモン人の女性としか一緒にならなかったと
それはね 犬はね 昔の犬もメス犬としか交尾しないんだよと
これで今の犬 やっぱりメス犬としか交尾しませんよと
ということは あなた方のしきたりは犬は守ってるんだけどね
あなた方破ってるんだよと
だから神の口から生まれた人に
お前は犬より以下やと言ってるでしょ
お釈迦様はすごい品格よく語るんだから気づかないだけで
えらい厳しい言葉なんですよ
そこでまた言うんですよ
昔のバラモン人の男は
女性が妊娠できる状況にならない限りは一緒にならないんだと
いわゆる性欲のために夫婦関係を持って持ってなかったんです
夫婦関係というのは大事なことで
子供を作るために行うんであって
そこ終わったらもう無欲で生活する
だから女性の体が妊娠できる状態になったら
そこででは子供を作りましょうよと
と一緒になるだけで でお釈迦様が言う
それはね 今ないんだと
今欲でどんな女でもいいんだと
バラモン人には どんな時期でも構わないんだと
しかし犬はね 昔も発情しているメス犬しか交尾しないんだと
しなかったんだと 今も犬は交尾するときは
メスが発情しているかないか調べてから交尾するんだと
やっぱりこのしきたり
しきたりは犬は守ってますよと
あなた方は守ってないんだいと言うんですね
だからこの経典で ものすごい厳しい言葉でバラモン人を非難していますね
これは非難はお釈迦様やりたくてやったんじゃないんです
本人が もう勝ったんだからね
ブッダは侮辱して勝ったんだから
勝ったからしょうがなくてあげなくちゃあかんでしょ
それでそうおっしゃったんですけど
この場合はこの激しく非難して批判したのは
この人間は生まれではないんだよと
あれは科学的な立場なんですね
人間 人間は人間の人生は行為で決まるんだと
あなたの生き方だよと
したがって善行為を行うべきですと
生まれどうでもいいんです
体が細くても太くてもどうでもいい
そんなのは 生活で良い人間になりなさいと
生き方で これは誰でもできますよと
いうことをお釈迦様は言いたいんですね
ですから 答えが決まってます
人間は善行為するべきです
もう話終わり そこで なぜ良いことをするのかというと
良い人間になるためなんです
まあ善行為も悪行為も別に五分五分でいいんじゃないってことは仏教はないんです
しかし 一切は全知全能の神によって創造されて
すべてが定められていると宗教家が説くならば
インドで一人がいたんですよ
運命論を語る人が すべて決まってますと
プログラムされてますと
生命は その人は人の努力
精進と道徳を否定するんですね
たとえ私は何者で生まれるのか
どんな仕事をするのか
どんな年で死ぬのかと
すべて神がプログラムして定めておいたならば
私は頑張ったって意味がないでしょう
神の計画から抜けられませんだから
この運命論を語ったのは
だからお釈迦様ははっきり批判するんです
あ そうか それだったら人殺し屋は人殺しをしているのは神がそう定めたからでしょ
盗人は盗みをやっているのは神がそう定めたからでしょ
だから人間何やったっても放っておく羽目になるんじゃないんですかね
人間が人殺しして文句言う権利ないでしょうにと
人間が大量大量殺人を起こしたっても
その人に文句を言う権利なくなるでしょうにと
いうことで お釈迦様は道徳を否定するんだと
この一神教は この一神教を語ったのはサンジェー・ベッラティプッタという
人なんです これは徹底批判しています
お釈迦様は どのように批判したか
これは小さな水の流れ
小川と言えるところではないんだけど
ちょっと川みたいにちょっと水が流れるところで網をセッティングしておく
まあ川が細くて小さいんだから簡単にできますね
そうなってくると お釈迦様は経典で明確に言うんですよ
水 水エビというんですか
あの いろいろ海の水の中で泳いでいるヘビたちがいるんですね
毒はないんですけどね
水ヘビやらカエルやら
海 水の上に生活している昆虫やら小魚やら大きい魚やら
みんなあの網にかかっちゃいますよと
誰も逃げられませんと
命を守ることはできないんだと
もしベッラティがベッラティプッタの教えが正しいと受け取ったら
まあ直行地獄やと 理由として言うのは
人間の努力を否定するんだと
人間が頑張って成長するべきということは
仏教ははっきりしているんです
仏教の考えは科学なんですよ
なぜならば 我々はいまも努力して成長しているんです
一つもただでもらったものはないんです
こういう建物も こういう音声機械もね
一つもただでもらったものじゃないんです
神が作ってくれたものは一つもないんです
我々は努力するんだから
野生で森の中で生活した人間が今
暖かい涼しい建物の中に住んでいるんですよ
それ否定するんですかね
昔は病気になったら動物と同じくそのまま死ぬしかなかったんです
しかし 人間頑張ったんです
なんで病気になるのか探したんです
それで対策を考えたんです
だから今 我々は病気になったっても
死ぬということはないんです
たとえ心臓がイカれたっても
もし運が良ければ新たな心臓を入れ替えてところ
入れ替えてもらうところまでできるんです
結構成長していますよ
死んだ人間の死んだ体の部品まで取り上げて
自分の体に患者の体に入れて
あの体を新しくリスタートする
それは素晴らしいことでしょう
だから なんで人間の努力を否定するんですかね
とってもかっこ悪いパラドックスなんですよ
だから科学発展するのも西洋なんですけど
で 徹底的に一神教をやってるのもそちらなんですけど
だからかなり分かれてますよ
もう結局は お互い仲良くはないんです
科学者を馬鹿にするローマ教皇も
病気になったらお医さんにお世話になる
恥ずかしいだと思いますよ
自分が祈って病気治ってもらえばいいでしょうに
それでは仏教はこのやっぱり科学的にはっきりとくっきりと言うんです
人間は努力するべき それ否定するならば
その人を助ける 次のポイントは皆様にも関係ある
身内の間でも寛容性はない
社会問題だけではありません
家族 親友の間でも寛容性はないんです
相手を自分の主観で批判するのです
家族の場合 親友の場合
結構やりますよ それは認めないんですね
相手の考えを 寛容は家族の中で
友人の間でスタートしなくてはいけないんですよ
ですから 我々はまず家族の中で寛容というものは実行しなくちゃ
それから友達の間で それから会社の仲間の間でとかね
そういう風に始めなくてはいけないんですね
相手の気持ちを理解する
相手の意見も尊重して聞き入れる
柔軟性っていうのは欠かせないんです
心にはメッターとカルナが欠けているんです
なんで家族の中でも対立はあるのかというと
家族はみんなお互い大事にしてますよ
大事にしているんですけど
慈しみがない メッタ カルナがない
カルナっていうのは心配する気持ち
哀れみの気持ち 助けてあげなくちゃとか
協力しなくちゃとかね
その 2つが弱いんですね
まずないんですね だから感情的に家族のことを大事にする
この感情は良くないんで
感情っていうのは所有欲なんです
だから我々は所有欲で家族を愛してますが
これって人間にとっては迷惑
迷惑なんです だから所有欲で家族を愛するのではなくて
慈しみで家族を愛する
メッカルナで家族を愛する
そうなってくると 素晴らしい家族関係
素晴らしい人間関係が出来上がるんです
はい これで差別についてブッダは認めませんと言いましたね
この差別を批判するとき
スッタニパータという経典にワセトスッタという経典がありまして
そちらにはバラモン人にものすごく怒鳴るんですよ
どのようにというと 人間は一種だよと
差がないんだと しかし
魚と鳥たちは違いますよと
魚 魚と獣たちはそれぞれ互い違いますよと
どのように違うかというと
生活習慣 子供を産むこと
子供の育ち方 食べるもの
そういうものは違いますよ
しかし 人間見たら食べるものも同じで
生命の行動すべて もう性性行為をどのようにするのかどうか
子供はどのように育てるのかどうかね
それは全部同じだと いわゆる明確な生物学なんですね
だから一種ですよと 余計なことを言うなよと
人間の差別はあるんだと
それにしても人間が何やるのかっていうことが問題だと
人間は盗むならば盗人だよと
バラモン人ではありませんと
人間は嘘つくならば嘘つきやと
バラモン人ではないんだと
だからカンマナワサローホーティ
行為によって卑しい人間になりますよと
カンマナーホーティブラフマノ
行為によって素晴らしい優れた人間になりますよということで
我々に行為に注意しなさいということを延々と語られています
はい それで差別について仏教の立場
次 先入観どうしましょうかと
これには精密な努力が必要ですよ
なぜかって 私に先入観があるかないかと
私が言うわからないでしょ
おそらくあると思いますけど
それってどっちかと自分ではわからないでしょ
だからこれ大きな問題なんですね
楽じゃない やっぱり先入観
先入観だからやめましょう
やめましょう そんなこと言ったってもね
私自身知ってますかね
私にどんな先入観があるのかと
私は結構私のことを疑問に思いますよ
時々私は仏教が正しくしっかり教えていると
ものすごく力強く言ってるでしょうに
他の人は絶対認めない態度でしょうね
あれ これってもしかすると先入観ではないかなとかね
だからどちらかというと
今日もヒンドゥー哲学のね
ヴェーダント哲学やらね
三家の一言 ちょこちょこちょこちょこと読もう読もうかなとしたんですけど
なんだこりゃってことで機嫌が悪くなっちゃってやめたんですね
これって先入観でしょうね
その時 あ これは先入観で
私は学生でいたならば
貪って貪って読む論文でしょうにと
今坊主という仕事をやってますから
まあ関係ないものは読まないと
あ これは先入観だなと
そういうわけで あの先入観から心を解放するのはちょっとややこしいんですよ
すべての生命は認識データを捏造して理解するんです
すべての生命 だから私は私に見えるもの
聞こえるもの 感じるもの
味わうもの 体に触れるものを捏造するんです
捏造して あ これを見えた
これを聞き 聞いた これを感じたと思うんです
これずっとやってるんです
このホールを見たら 私は私なりの捏造するんです
まあ正直に言いますけどね
結構古いボロくそホールだなとかね
ボロボロだなと だからそう言っていいんですかね
まあ言ってない 今言いましたけどね
そう思っていいんですかね
思っていいわけじゃないんだけど
パッと見ちゃうと 頭の中でもうね
粗しちゃうんですね あ
振るとかね でもちゃんと使えますけどね
というわけで これがこの
そういうプロセスなんです
これ 皆様どうかなとわからないんだから
私はこの極端な例を出すんですよ
まあ例えばね あのネズミが死んじゃって
まあ 3日も経ってウジ虫も出ていて臭いんですね
これ見たら皆様 あ これ結構ごちそうや思う
あ これごちそうや 美味しそうですね
思わないね しかし カラスなんかはどうですかね
これをきれいに食べる動物はいくらでもいるんです
ウジ虫いたってもどうでもいいんです
細菌いたっても全然平気じゃない
だから私たちはおにぎり一個見たら
なかなか美味しそうだなと思うんであって
だから我々は自分の体に合うものを選んで食べているでしょ
あれ ネズミ機能なきゃ大変なことになりますよ
だからある程度で命を守るためにネズミが必要なんです
で 科学発展もね 相当ネズミの仕事から出ていく
現れますよ ただ 昔はこの道具なかったでしょ
道具なかったんだけど
人間が体が弱いし あの虎が締めた獲物かもしれませんだけど
虎が出て行ったら人間が後ろから来て食べなくちゃあかんですね
硬くて このもう歯が弱くて
もう虎は食べますけど
人間に食べられないんですね
そのまま死んだ鹿の肉は
それでいろいろ考えたんですよ
これ何か砕いた方がいいんじゃないか
それで石とかね 見つけちゃって
これで叩いちゃうと割れちゃうんで
小さな部品に あの肉は口に入られるようなところで
それで土の上で石でトントンってやっても肉は切れませんね
それで石のあれ 切れる石
ちょっと小さな石を持って
別な大きな石の上に置いてとんとんと叩いて切って食べたりしたでしょ
だからこれね そうしなきゃできない仕事なんです
そこで火を発見したでしょ
誰か神様が持ってきたという話もありますけどね
で 火を発見してね ああ
これ焼いちゃった 食べた方が食べやすいんだなと
で そういうことで人間どんどんどんどん発展していきました
かなりスピードに発展しました
だからやっぱりね 想像機能があったんだからこそできるものなんですね
この建築家なんかはね
例えばこのホールをね
デザインした建築家がね
見てないんで こんなのは
自分の好きな紙の上でね
いろいろ線描いたり あれやこれやしたりして
だから結構ね 粗をしているんですよ
そこでこの捏造という言葉
なんで私は使うのかというと
仏教専門用語はパパンチャなんですね
で パパンチャは捏造でも
私は捏造という言葉はすごい気に入ってますけど
現象を作るっていう意味なんです
あのデータには現象がないんです
あの目には あの私の目にこのホールは映りません
ホールの形は頭の中で作るんです
イメージを この脳の中で起こる作業にパパンチャというんです
皆様に私は日本語で喋っているとは聞こえません
ただ音しか聞こえないんです
その音を頭の中でイメージ化する
イメージ作るんです それは日本語になったり
言葉になったり 意味になったりします
これはパパンチャ機能なんです
これがなければ生命ではないんですよ
大変なことなんです しかし
なんで私は捏造という言葉を使うんですかね
捏造っていうのは勝手にできません
ある程度データが必要なんです
例えば この 私の前を見て
ああ 綺麗な公園だなと思える？思えません
思ったら病気です だから何かデータが入るんですよ
このデータによって私はホールだとして古という捏造が出ちゃったんです
で 古いと思ったら自分勝手
科学的じゃないんです
古いっていうのは論理的に言えば何年経ったら古い？ないでしょうに
だからえらい主観ですごい勝手なんですね
はい それでデータがあって捏造する
捏造するということは自分の都合なんです
だから人間が人間の都合で捏造するんだから
人間が発達してもしてもしても
野生のクマにとってはね
何の役にも立ちませんね
野生の猿たちに何の役にも立ちません
かえってえらい迷惑なんですね
それで皆様が疑問とするでしょう
だからパンダが助かっているんではないかと
パンダの立場から見ればね
人間の発展でえらい迷惑で
パンダっていうのは このダーウィンさんの生命の法則っていうテキストを読んでないんだそうです
他の動物はみんな読んでるんです
だから環境に適応しようとするんです
子孫を作ろうとするんです
あの連中だけ怠け者で
このダーウィンさんの本を読んでないんです
だから交尾しないわ 環境に適応しないわ
自分の子供で見るとびっくりしちゃって殺しに行くわ
他の同じパンダ見ても怯えるわ
だからあの連中はエクスティンクションって何でしたっけ？殲滅するしかないんですよ
しかし 人間がものすごい金をかかっていわゆる今自然を守る時のあれもパンダでしょ
何かありますね シールがね
パンダなんですね それで皆様に理論できますよ
反論できますよ 人間が開発
発展 技術開発したんだからパンダが助かっているんでよと
でもそうですかね なんでパンダが絶滅するになったんですかね
人間のせいでしょうね
そういうわけで 人間が科学的に
文化的に 経済的に開発しますけど
これ我々の都合でやっているんです
他の人に関係ないんです
他の生命体に はい これネズソ論というのは
今日はあんまり言ってはいけないなと思っていたんですけど
言ってしまっちゃった
で これで私は何を言いたがっているのかと
このネズソ論で これ今まで覚えましょう
ネズソとは偉そうにネズソ悪いと喋ってる
私もやってます 皆様もやってます
犬も猫もカラスもやってます
それで次のこと問題なんです
これ 私におにぎりが美味しそうに見えるでしょ？私にネズミの死骸は
えっ ちょっと気持ち悪くと見えるでしょ
それで私が自分が正しいと思うんですね
だって正しいもん だっておにぎり食べられますからね
死んだ腐ったネズミ食えないでしょうね
食っちゃったら病気になって自分が死ぬかもしれませんね
微生物にやられちゃって
だから死んだネズミの死骸が気持ち悪い
不潔っていうことも おにぎりが美味しいということも
私にとっては正しいんです
だからいつだって俺は正しいんです
ここが問題なんです もうわかったんでしょうかね
ネズソはしちゃいます
次のステップなんです
問題は ネズソの欠点いう私は決しておにぎりを置いておいてネズミは食べませんよ
そこまで生命を維持するためにはもう欠かせないんですね
ネズソは セカンドステップなんですよ
故に我は正しいというところ
例えばこちら おにぎり 2 3個
皿にあります 右側にサンドイッチを 3枚やります
としましょう そこで日本人とヨーロッパ人が二人を立ってます
それで日本の方はどっちを食べようかなと言ったら
すぐおにぎりに手が行くんですね
やっぱりおにぎりが美味しくて体にいいんだと
梅干しも入ってるし 海苔も入ってる
健康的で もしかすると
このヨーロッパの人は
え？これ食う？まあドイツ人にしましょうか
ドイツ人はい ご飯食べる
サンドイッチでしょうにと
ドイツ人はパンばっかり食ってますからね
私は聞いたんですよ 我々はむちゃくちゃご飯食べてますけど
あんた方は全然食わないでしょ
肉ばっかり食いやがっちゃってとかね
あんたの人生で牛何頭ぐらい食ってるんですか？と言ったら
その人はね まあ私はいつもそういう辛口言うんだからね
いや ご飯食べますよと
ありますか？いくらでもありますよと
すごい威張ってるんですね
いくらでもありますよと
マーケットではね まあスーパーマーケットでどうやって食べるの？と言ったら
まあまあマヨネーズかけたり
バターをかけたりとかね
あれ サラダそうです ご飯というのはサラダサラダなんです
あの日本の方々も あの
ジャガイモ潰したものはポテトサラダと言って食べてるでしょ
私は食べません あれはサラダではありません
私にとってはただの芋なんです
私にとってサラダっていうのはやっぱり野菜なんです
だからご飯も食べてポテトサラダ
今日はサラダとご飯食べてるんだから完璧だと私は思いません
で 考えてください ご飯にマヨネーズかけて食べる
と言ったっても 日本人も食べてますよ
コンビニではマヨネーズかけたおにぎり売ってますからね
まあまっすぐないんですよ
で 言いたいところはこれなんです
日本人は日本人の文化によって
習慣や習慣によって あなたどちらにしますか？と言ったら
おにぎりにします ヨーロッパ人があなたどちらにしますか？と言ったら
サンドイッチ サンドイッチにします
もしこの二人がこういうこと言ったらどうなりますかね
え？日本人がね あのね
あなたこれサンドイッチ食うんですかね
こんな美味しいご飯あるのに
こんなのは食いもんじゃないよと言ったら
ヨーロッパ人が腹が立つでしょう
逆にヨーロッパの方が
え？あんたご飯食べてる？こんなサンドイッチあるのに
サンドイッチにしなさいよと
このステージはダメでしょ
ここはダメなんです 我は正しいところはダメなんです
これがねつ造から出てくる問題なんです
この寛容ということは
なくなるのは我は正しいからなんです
どうにもならなくなっているんです
だから 無批判的にいい加減で
寛容 寛容と謳うなよと私は言いたいんです
相当結構大変だと そこで自分に見える世界のみが本物という気持ちになります
他人にどのように世界を見るかは知る方法もなさそうです
ないんです で 釈尊はありのままに如実に観察する修行方法を説かれます
そこでお釈迦様があのね
訓練しましょうよと ねつ造するしない訓練
ねつ造する訓練は要りませんね
どうせやっちゃいますから
ではねつ造しない訓練もやる
ねつ造しない訓練をやってみれば問題解決
これは私に見える世界
他の生命にはこのように見えませんと
ねつ造の場合はそう思うんです
しかし ねつ造しない訓練も知ってるんだから
データはこれこれこれこれです
このデータから私はこのようにねつ造しました
この方は同じデータからこのようにねつ造しました
ということで終わり 話は
それによって 怒りも欲も嫉妬も何もあんた変と出てこないんです
おにぎり美味しいと思っているあなたは変だよと
サンドイッチは食べたくないと言っているあなたは変だよとかね
あのバターの場合は 日本は最初はすごくみんな嫌がったでしょ
だってそうです 昔ね まあ私は勉強していたところでバター臭いという表現もあるみたいですね
いわゆる否定的な言葉みたいですね
今みんな料理に何でも使ってますけど
はい だから当時でバターを食べる習慣がなかったんだから
ねつ造機能が働き出しちゃって
あんなのはもう臭いとまずいということにしちゃったでしょう
そういうことで 熱想しない訓練してみれば
心にあるこのエゴは 我は正しいという気持ち消えちゃう
これでものすごく自由になるんです
いわゆる熱想機能は完全壊れたわけじゃないんです
壊れちゃうと生きていられなくなっちゃいます
熱想機能は完全安全で働くんです
トラブルはない えーと
時計があったんだけど
うん はい 仏教の答えはこれなんですよ
熱想をやめましょうよと
ではなくて 熱想をやめる訓練しましょうよと
訓練成功したら心はきれいになります
これで問題解決と 意見主義などの対立
次のテーマ ブッダのこのような
ブッダはこのような喧嘩を避けるようにアドバイスなさいます
この意見の対立 議論とか
お釈迦様は比丘たちに言うんです
避けなさいと言うんです
なぜならば無意味です
それぞれの主観偏見を言い争っても結論はないし
負けたら悔しいし 勝っても自分が正しいかどうか分からないし
心を清らかにする義務に関係がないんです
だからこの議論することはあんまり仏教は好まないんです
しかし えらい上手ですけど
できるだけ避けなさいと
Aさんは Aさんの意見を持っていて
Bさんは Bさんの意見を持っていて
どちらが正しいかと議論しちゃうと
いい加減やめなさいと
仏教の立場では どちらでたっても大した考えではないし
議論したっても結論に達するわけでもないし
結論に立ったんだからといって別にどうったことはないし
それより仕事は心を清らかにすることでしょうと
はい 次 政治的な話 軍事に関わる話
世間話などは禁止するんです
やるなよと 寛容ではなくて禁止
なぜならば 政治的な話をすると
決して寛容ではいられません
相手を倒さなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
軍事に関わる話しちゃうと
自分の身も危険にさらされる可能性もあります
だからこれは禁止ですね
トラブルを招く 心が汚れる
はい えーと  新しいテーマなんですけど
他の批判を聞き入れる
これ 仏教の立場なんです
パーリ聖典の最初のテキストの最初の経典で
このポイントを語るんです
まあ一応戒律テキストは先に出してますけど
我々は戒律を読まないんだから
経典を読んでいるでしょ
だから経典はグループ５つに分けてあって
この 1番目のグループ
長部経典と言うんですね
これは長部経典の経典第1号に
この寛容について語っています
ディーガニカーヤの1番目の経典
ブラフマジャーラ・スッタン
釈尊と 250人の比丘たちがラージャガハとナーランダの間
旅に出ています 遊業者のスッピヤも同じ道を歩いている
遊業者っていうのは仏教ではなくて
別な宗教の人なんです
彼が徹底的に仏法僧を非難
侮辱をする 一緒に旅に出ているのくせに
これはあの 3ページぐらい 1
ページぐらい縮めたんですね
あの経典では長く 美しく
わかりやすく書いています
スッピヨピコパリッバジャコ
アネーカパリヤエーナ
ブッダッサアワンナンバセティ
ダンマッサアワンナンバセティ
サンガッサアワンナンバセティ
次の彼の弟子ブラフマダッタ
スッピヤッサパリッバッジャガッサ
アンテーワーシーブラフマダットマナヴォ
というふうに原文であります
ちょっと暗記しているんだと見せたかっただけ
えーと 彼の弟子ブラフマダッタという若者が徹底的に仏法僧を賛嘆するんです
ちょっとイメージしてください
ラージャガハというのはすごい大きな町で
これからナーランダまでかなり遠いんですよ
かなり遠い 車で行っても
で その間で行く行くんですね
だいたい旅出る 旅に出る修行者が期間も決まってるんだから
どんな宗教の方々もだいたい一緒に会ったりはします
ブッダと 200  250人ぐらいの坊さんたちが歩いていると
このグループもその道に入ったんですね
そこで先生はスッピヤさんが仏法僧の非難
侮辱ばっかりして 弟子のブラフマダッタ若者が仏法僧を賛嘆しているんです
比丘は夜このように話し合う
人間の性格は様々ですと
釈尊に説かれたのはまさにその通りですね
パーリ語で見ましょうか
もう自分はするしかないんですね
スッピヤとブラフマだったが
師弟関係なのに互いに正反対の意見を持ってますと
これで面白いでしょう
このエピソードは実際にあったものだからね
何か面白いというと このスッピヤさんが弟子を育てていますよ
若者を ブラフマダッタという名前の
だからインド文化では師弟関係っていうのはかなり硬いんですよ
すごく愛情で結んで結ばれているんです
親子関係で だから全然怖い関係じゃないんです
わがままも言っちゃうし
もう親子関係なんですね
これで先生の先生がブッダを非難しているのに
弟子が偉そうに若いくせにブッダってすごいですよと言っちゃうと
日本だったら即座に破門でしょ
絶対認めないでしょ 昔からインドではね
まあスッピヤさんが別に弟子弟子がもう散々ブッダのせい散々することを別にもう聞いて聞いてないふりでしょうね
お前何と言ったってブッダは悪いと
え？そんなこと先生おっしゃってお釈迦さん素晴らしい人やと何言うのがあいつは悪いやと
そんな感じで話し合ったでしょうね
だから私があえて言いたいのは
このスッピヤとブラフマダッタの間でも寛容性があったんです
だから師弟関係なんです
意見はすごい正反対 ここで釈尊は仏教的な寛容について語ります
他人が仏法僧を非難しても
あなた方はタトラトゥンミーヒナ
アーガートナアッパッチョーナ
チェータソーアナビラッディカーニーヤ
わかりますか？わからない
困った で ブッダを非難しても
愚痴を非難しても サンガを非難しても
あなた方はアーガーと怒ってはいけませんので
アッパッチよ 機嫌悪くしてはいけませんと
なチェーテスを穴開ける
だからアッパッチョっていうのは
居心地が悪くなる まあまあ
ちょっと逃げましょうとかね
チェーテスワナビラディっていうのは機嫌が悪くなる
それはやめなさいよと
人はもう散々非難 侮辱
冒涜している しかし あなた方は嫌な気持ちになってはなりませんよ
と 怒ってはならない 居心地悪くなってはならない
心に悩みが起きてはならないとお釈迦様は言うんです
トゥンハンエーヴァッサテーナアンタラーヨ
それはあなた方の心の障害になるんだと
だから面白い話ですよ
あの非難がどうでもいいんです
非難に対して自分が気持ち悪くなったら
この気持ち悪くなったことが障害であると
何に障害になりますかね
ネズソをやめる訓練の障害になるんです
だって気持ち悪くなった時点でネズソでしょ
だから微妙に気をつけなくちゃいかんですよ
特に出家はね 非難すると批判すると
すごくそのまま冷静で明るくていなくちゃいかんのです
で もしあなたたちは批判に対して怒ったなら
ならばアピネトゥンヘーパレサン
すばしたん ドゥッ バシタン
アージャーネーヤート
他人が怒ったらね 他人が正しく批判しているのか
根拠のない批判しているのか知ることはできますかと
ということは 批判をちゃんと聞きなさいなんです
もしかすると本当のことを言っているかもしれません
もしかするといい加減なことを言っているかもしれません
それはわからなくなるでしょうと
怒ったら で 比丘たちはできませんと答えるんですね
反対に仏法僧を賛嘆されても喜んではならない
舞い上がってはならない
タトラトゥンメヒナアーナンドーナソーマナッサンナチェーテソウッピラーヴィタッタン
このチェーテソウッピラーヴィタッタンからすごくなんかウキウキする状態に絶対なるなよと
あなた方にとってはそれが障害になりますと
賛嘆されたならば ありのままに
そういえば このような特色が我々にありますと理解すれば十分ですと
ああ そういえば まあそうですねと
しかし 心はウキウキ状態にしてはいけません
みんなに褒められている
売れているとかね はないんです
はい これが寛容です だから仏教はそこから始めてますよ
仏教と俗世間は認めない教え
仏教っていうのは ああ
なんか休憩取る時間なくなっちゃいますね
どうですかね まあ一応
じゃあ佐藤さん あまり時間はないんですけど
30分  はい では 5分ぐらい
では 5分ぐらい トイレ休憩にします
はい これからちょっとスピードを上げます
あの仏教の教えはね ちょっと問題がありますよ
この世間 俗世間は認めないものばっかりなんです
俗世間の知識では理解できない教えです
皆様ご存知ですね お釈迦様は悟り開いてからね
説法なんかするもんかいと思ったでしょ
最初はこんな迷惑やと
人間は理解できないんだと
私も大変で 人間も大変だと
だからそれぐらい仏教の内容は難しいんです
で 超人的な真理を語っています
俗世間の流れの反対の道を説かれています
だから俗世間はいっぱい金を儲けなさいと言っているところ
お釈迦様は執着を捨てなさいと言うんです
家族がいればなんて幸せでしょうかと世間が言う場合は
お釈迦様は家族こそが煩わい
煩い 煩いのもとであると
なんかすごいややこしいんですよ
ではそうは言わないんだけど
いわゆる悩み苦しみを作る種は家族ですよと
というふうに言うんです
そうなってくると もうやっぱり違いますよと言いたくなりますよ
でも事実ですけどね でもなのに違うと言いたくなっちゃうんですね
まあ親たちがもう子供のせいで悩んでるでしょ
人の子供のこと悩まないでしょ
だからといって それは言って欲しくないんですね
だからこそ 四種という立場で
挑戦的な立場で真理をあらわにするんです
ですから お釈迦様がこのある手段をとったんですよ
挑戦で喋りますと 四苦おで喋りますと
いわゆるこれが真理です
間違うとも 間違いなら証明しなさいと
誰でもいいんだよと この教えは真理でないと言える人はいませんよと
この存在の中でというすごい態度
強い態度で語っていくんです
なんでその態度をとるのかというと
そうでない限りは 人間があのね
家族こそが幸せだよと言うんです
それ言わせないんです
じゃあ証明しなさい 立証しなさいと言うんで
お釈迦様は そう言われると
みんなちょっと怖くなっちゃって
それはちょっとごめんと
理性のない愚か者はブッダに寛容性がない
他人の教えを認めないと批判批判するところです
特に西洋でちょこちょことテキストをなめる方々は
ブッダにも寛容性がないというのはそういうところなんです
これ 寛容性ではないではないんですよ
すごい優れている立場なんです
絶対的な挑戦で喋ってるんです
科学者もしないことなんです
宗教家には絶対無理 宗教家の教えはスーッと攻撃を受けっぱなしで
壊れっぱなしで ブッダの教えは全然何言われたっても壊れないというすごい立場なんですね
だからそういうふうに喋る羽目になったんです
そこでブッダの立場 ダンマパダ 320 アハンナーゴーサンガーメーチャーパートパティタンサランアティワーキャンティティキッサンドゥッシーローホバッ
ジャノ
戦闘に関わっている いわゆる戦闘をしている象が放たれた矢を忍耐するように
私は人の言い過ぎた言葉を忍耐する
なぜならば 一般人には心の戒めはないからです
だからお釈迦様は覚悟の上
くたくた言われますと
仏教に対しては まあそれは別に当たり前だと
みんな心の訓練してないんだと
ブッダの勧業は俗人の勧業とは違います
ですから あなたにも一理ありではないんです
あなた心の訓練してないでしょ？ネズソと我は正しい態度でしょ
じゃあまあいいよ 言いたい放題言ってもという態度なんですね
それから皆様が半分ぐらいの方々暗記していますね
サッブパパサからなんくさらすぷさんぱださちっとバリヨダかな
これがブッダの教えですと
悪をやらないこと 善を行うこと
心を洗浄すること 洗うこと
きれいにすること これが問題ですと
それからカンティパラマンタポーティティッカ
忍耐 勧業であることこそが修行ですよと
勧業とは修行なんです
宗教の真理と目的 登攀する道
登山する道はたくさんあっても
頂上に輝く月の光は同じですという
これは丸ごと人の言葉パクっちゃったんです
どうであれ バラエティズオブウェイストゥクライムマウンテン
バッド バッドムーンシャイニングオンザトップイズセイムフォーオールというね
教えと修行方法は違っても
たどり着く目的は同じですという意味なんですね
無知な世間がよく歌うフレーズです
私から見れば アホしかそんなこと言わないんです
仏教はそれを認めません
神を信仰する宗教の場合は
このように考えても構わない
だから世の中を創った新規神の神というのはたくさんいるでしょ
我こそ唯一神という神は結構いるんですね
だからみんな同じだというのは一向に構わないんですよ
私も同じだと思った方が世界は平和になると思います
アッラーという神も イエホワという神も
キリストという神も アフラ・マッダでも何でもかんでもね
何でしたっけ？日本にいる神は
みんな同じやと思った方が世界は平和になりますけど
仏教では神がいないんだからね
一即一切は大乗仏教だけではなく
ヒンドゥー教の考えでもあります
大乗仏教はよく言うんですね
一即一切と 禅のお坊さんたちも言うんですね
一とはすべてある すべてとは一であると
まあ相当アホでしょうね
なんとなくいいことを言っちゃったと気がするでしょ？何も言ってないんです
で それでこの親鸞晩鐘はすべて真理として一つであると言いたいんです
様々な現象があっても
もとは一つであると言いたいところですね
これはヒンドゥー教でも言ってます
仏教はそれと違うことを言っているんです
仏教の目的 生きること
存在 そのものが苦ですと
渇愛によって苦が連続しますと
渇愛を根絶することでのみ苦を乗り越えられると
だから話違いますよ 神がいるかいなかなくて
君 あんた生きること楽苦って
大変でしょう お釈迦様って
とジョークで始まるんです
楽じゃないんだよと そうね
君も生きていきたいと
すごい執着べったしだからね
相当苦しいでしょうねと
だから放っておけと 訓練しなさいと
すごく楽になりますよという話は仏教なんですね
この道は中道である 八正道です
それ以外 解脱に達する方法はありません
存在しないんです 四聖諦と八正道を語っているのは釈迦牟尼ブッダのみです
聖者は仏教にのみ存在しますと
全く勧誘ではありませんね
最後になってくると 仏教の目的
ディーガニカーヤのスッタナンバー18 マハパリニッバーナスッタンとありまして
そこでマハーパリニッバーナというのは大きなテキストぐらいものすごい長いんです
分厚いテキストぐらい長いんです
そちらである セクションスバッダパリパッバッジャカターというセクションがあります
これ誰か入れた可能性もあります
もしかすると涅槃経だから
別にお釈迦様喋ったものではないんです
お釈迦様が喋ったものを合わせて合わせて
お釈迦様の涅槃の最後を記録したんです
お釈迦様の体を荼毘にするところまで
だからお釈迦様ではないのは当然でしょ
だからこれ入れた可能性もあります
編集した阿羅漢のお坊さんたちが
釈尊が涅槃に入る直前に
スバッダという行者が
お釈迦様に会いたいというんですよ
お釈迦様はあと2  3時間で涅槃に入るんですよ
亡くなるんです この変な宗教が来てね
お釈迦様に会わせてくださいと言うんです
アーナンダ尊者は断りますと
今そんなところではありませんと
あと間もなくお釈迦様がもう亡くなりますと
言って ここで喧嘩するんですね
アーナンダ尊者と だからぜひ会わせてくださいと
だから会わせませんよとアーナンダ尊者言うんです
お釈迦様に聞こえたんですね
聞こえたら何の騒ぎですかと
ったら アーナンダ尊者がお釈迦様はこの時間で
この連中はね 会いたいと言うんだから
まあまあ通しなさいってお釈迦様が言うんです
言ったら スバッダという行者がお釈迦様に会うんですね
会って長い質問するんですね
お釈迦様はこのインドではたくさん宗教があります
たくさん宗教方法があります
修行方法が みんな最終目的解脱としていろんなことを語ってます
これで私が悩んでますと
もしかするとみんなの教えが違っても
修行方法が違っても みんな同じ目的を指しているんではないかと
思います お釈迦様どう思います？喋る力がないんですよ
もう 80歳でも倒れていてね
また 1 日 2 日もう赤痢で
その夜命がなくなるんです
お釈迦様は面倒くさいんだからすぐ答えたんです
仏教だけが真理を語っているのだと
しかし 論理的に言うんですよ
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
四聖諦を理解しないで
八正道を実践しないで解脱に達するということはありえませんと
いわゆる生きることは苦である
渇愛は苦の原因である
渇愛をなくすべきである
生きることをなくすのではなくて
渇愛をなくすためには
正見 正思惟 正語 なんだらなんだらなんだらという八正道ですね
それを実践しなくちゃいけない
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
この八正道を誰がやっても悟れますよと
まず言うんです どんな人間が四聖諦を理解して八正道を実践したっても
これは悟りますよと しかしですね
八正道を語っているのは私だけだと
四聖諦を語っているのは私だけですと
他の人は語っていないんだと
ですから 結果として第一の沙門も第二の沙門も
第三の沙門も第四の沙門も
この教えにあるんだと
沙門というのは聖者なんですね
これは決して勧誘的な言葉ではなさそうに感じますけど
本当は違います 論理的に語っているだけなんです
最後だから本当のことを言っちゃったんです
と言ったら ずっと本当のことを言ってましたけど
社会的な遠慮はもう捨てたんですね
すんやっぱわだサマニー
これは厳しい言葉なんですね
他人の教えはもう空っぽ
虚しいんだと 何に空かというと
聖者がいないんだと 空き家だと
八正道を実践するならば
この世にいつでも聖者が現れますと
全く寛容と言えない言葉を語ったんです
全部教典の引用です 教典の訳なんです
はい これでまとめましょう
世間が謳っている寛容は大したことではありません
寛容と言いつつも 差別と先入観を無視する
それに気づいていない
心が汚れなく清らかであることは真の寛容です
心に汚れがないならば
これで大らかで柔軟性で何でも受け入れる大きい心なんですね
人格向上を意味します
ですから 寛容とは人格向上なんですよ
こんなただで貰うものじゃないんで
寛容はただでただではありません
修行の結果達する境地です
人格向上です 解脱です
で終わりです ということで
仏教の寛容論というのは結構レベル高いということだけね
理解してください まあ世間で言っている普通のね
で 寛容っていうのはそれも大事なものなんでしょ
そのとき我々が気をつけるのは
人間はディファレンツ違いますよと
これ認めましょう そば好きでたまらない人も
うどんうどん好きでたまらない人いますから
そこらへんは放っておきましょう
どちらが正しいじゃないでしょ
この認める大きさがね
それもそんなに難しくないんです
だから世間的に寛容でいられるのはそんなに難しくないんです
だから僕は腰抜けは認めません
何が正しいかということははっきり決まっています
その場合は厳しく真理を語らなくちゃあかん
例えば ある人が私はコンビニ強盗をしたいと思っていると
なんでやというと だってバイト下がったんだからないんですよと
美味しいものを食いたくなっちゃったと
パチンコやりたくなっちゃったと
金がないし それであなた寛容だからね
どうします？寛容的な立派な人間だから
どうする？あ そうそう
それはまあ 意見には人にはね
そういう生き方もあります
それで寛容と思う だから
真理は真理ですよ その時偉そうな変な観をしてね
そいつは泥棒に仕立てるのはよくないでしょ
そんなことやるなよと
お金がなかったら別に飢えに飢え死になったってもかっこいいでしょうにと
なんで恥ずかしいことするのかと
だったらどこかに行って土下座でお願いしますよと
食ってないんだと 二日間も何か食っておくれと言ったらくれますよと
悪いことだけするなよと
死んでもと言うべきでしょ
それでもやるならば先に連絡します
警察にと そういうふうな手を回して
でもそこは悪いことからやめさせなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからそこを理解してください
観行っていうのは優柔不断でどうでもいいやという感じじゃないんです
はい 今日で話は終わりましたけど
まあ師匠 哲学の方々いるならばまだあることはあるんですね
結構ジャイナ教のジャイナ教って結構寛容なんですよ
ジャイナ教 皆さんは知らないね
じゃあやめましょう まあこれから英語になりますからね
まあありますけどね はい
どうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました
それではちょうど時間に近くなりましたので
皆さんで回向の文を行して終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビートゥエワッジャントゥ サンブローゴ ヴィナッサトゥ マハーテー バワット パンティ ラヨー スケー ディーガー
イコー バワ バウトゥ サッバ マングララン ラッカントゥ サンバ デヴァタ サンバ ブンダンバーヴェーナ サッバ
ダンマ アヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガ アヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダナ シ
ーリス ニッチャン ワッダ パチャヤーノ チャッターロ ダンマー ワッダンティ アユワッノー スカン バラン
ありがとうございます
今日は本当に長い時間どうもありがとうございます
[applause]